was das licht an leuchtet wird sichtbar
wir sehen also nicht das ding selbst
sondern nur die strahlen die von ihm
reflektiert werden
ich reflektiere also bin ich
[Musik]
überall leuchtet das licht ist
allgegenwärtig
aber was ist licht für ein seltsamer
stock ist es überhaupt ein stoff oder
reine energie nicht ist uns nur
scheinbar vertraut photonen
lichtteilchen öffnen die tore zu einer
völlig seltsam welt früher dachte man
kleine kügelchen schwirren durch die
gegend dann hielt man licht für eine
welle heute weiß man je nachdem welche
experimente man anstellt ist diesmal das
eine und mal das andere nicht ist eine
welle andererseits licht ist ein
teilchen und je nachdem wie cns
beobachter ist es irgendwie war es
beides gleichzeitig das ist auch richtig
bezahlt
es kann ja nicht nur bizarr sein das
licht es ist stickig da man sieht es im
wahrsten sinne des wortes ja dauernd
aber wenn man genauer hinguckt sieht man
praktisch nichts mehr
spätestens dann wenn man versucht ein
photon auf die waage zu leben
ja das ist wirklich auf den ersten blick
etwas merkwürdig
also wir ich sitze hier auf dem stuhl
und habe natürlich dann eine bestimmte
masse wenn jetzt hier eine vage wäre das
wäre dann meine ruhe masse und das gilt
auch für elementarteilchen wie das
proton und das neue thron des gerätes
aus denen wir ja auch bestehen nun beim
photon ist das anders das hat
tatsächlich ruhe masse 0
also ist es da und gleichzeitig doch
nicht da das photon ist aber nie in ruhe
sagen die physiker sondern bewegt sich
ständig und natürlich nicht irgendwie
sondern mit lichtgeschwindigkeit wo die
nächste merkwürdigkeit steckt auf den
ersten blick ist das licht einfach nur
schnell wenn man es auf die reise
schickt in 13 sekunden bis zum mond oder
in einer sekunde sieben mal um die erde
herum
hebt man den blick recht und kosmos
klingt das gar nicht mehr so doll
denn bis zum saturn dem fernen planeten
den man in unserem sonnensystem noch mit
dem bloßen auge sieht braucht das licht
schon anderthalb stunden oder bis zum
nächsten start vier jahre
und bis zur andromeda-galaxie braucht es
ganz arten welche 4,5 millionen jahre
300 tausend kilometer pro sekunde
das ist nicht irgendeine geschwindigkeit
mehr geht nicht unter keinen umständen
das licht aus einem scheinwerfer wird
nicht das geringste bisschen schneller
und sich das auto zusätzlich bewegt
braucht es auch nicht nicht bewegt sich
immer mit lichtgeschwindigkeit und ich
kann das nicht agieren
das hat aber sofort wenn man darüber
nach eine halbe stunde nachdenkt die
konsequenz dass die zeit nicht immer
gleich schnell vergeht
dank einstein wer allerdings mehr als
eine halbe stunde brauchte wissen wir
dass raum und zeit sich verzerren wenn
wir uns bewegen
je schneller wir unterwegs sind desto
stärker ist die verzerrung und das
photon bewegt sich mit 300.000
kilometern pro sekunde sehr schnell die
verzerrung ist bei dieser
geschwindigkeit so extrem dass die zeit
aus der sicht des photons stillsteht in
der raum keine ausdehnung mehr hat
schneller wäre also sinnlos perspektive
des photons
das universum keiner aus dem noch mehr
ich bin überall im universum
gleichzeitig jetzt können wir uns leider
in die foto und perspektive nicht
versetzen das war ja eine tolle nummer
wenn wir den zugucken könnten und die
perspektive auch halten weil leider
jeder körper der eine masse hat jeder
körper der schwer ist der gewicht hat
braucht unendlich viel energie um auf
lichtgeschwindigkeit zu kommen das foto
und wäre was her
na ja sehr exotisches ausschuss ist
endet dann eigentlich keinen raum und
keine zeit kein wunder dass licht
besinnlichkeit stiftet mein umgang mit
liegt ist schon auch alltagstauglich
aber das licht auf einer ebene
geheimnisvoll ist die jetzt nicht
mystisch oder romantisch ist das
begleitet mich schon durchaus natürlich
manchmal vielleicht in einem ruhigen
augenblick oder wenn man den gerade
entspannt natürlich klar
überlege ich mir wie bietet sich jetzt
das ein was ich jetzt hier jeden tag
nach in eigentlich die grundlegenden
gleichungen die grundlegenden gesetze
der natur
[Musik]
das licht erinnert eben in die tiefsten
rätsel der welt nicht nur auf den
altären vieler religionen sondern auch
in den geschmeidigen gehirnen der
physiker